yeah I got I got offered a movie the
other day just a straight up offer to be
in a movie it was another zombie film
and we all know how much how many films
about my zombie films were gone
and I think I'm not even their first
choice right they've rang a few people
and we've got the movie The Other lead
was going to be uh Vanilla Ice it was
gonna be mean Villa lights and zombies
that movie's coming out bad it's coming
out with someone else besides yeah
were you playing yourself are you
playing a character I think it was I
think I believe vanilla rice is playing
vanilla rice and then yeah then he meets
me somewhere in the apocalypse and then
wrap myself in the third person then Jim
Jefferies and vanilla rice
back and accept this
yes the next cocaine bear the Knicks no
only be one cocaine yeah